now from all of this right what this
tells the transition to is a bunch of
questions if manipulating and combining
these different results of different
ways I will show you those example in a
second but I have to justify for you and
I got to two big reasons why any of this
is like what's the point of all this
what's like why do we bother ladies hang
on are three reasons for the first
reason I just need a bit of space young
the first reason is what I say here is
we know these relationships between what
these roots are and we can get them very
very simply like you just have to read
off what the coefficients are and divide
a pair of numbers like how easy does it
get okay now
the enormity of that is probably lost on
you a little bit because we're quite
used to finding roots and knowing what
they are okay if I give you something I
like even something a bit awkward like
this okay like this is this is not like
how actually no that's too high okay
this is gonna have some roots you can
find them with the quadratic formula
okay you can add them you can subtract
them no big deal okay
that's because the quadratic formula
despite what the disaster it looks like
when you first learn it it's actually
not that hard to work with like it
doesn't take that long to memorize to
see it's not that complicated okay but
as you add layers of complexity as you
go to say the cubing things get a little
bit difficult so thank you for my
helpers who gave me right I'm doing it
this way because I I don't want to write
out the cubic formula because this is
what the Q before looks like now just
look at it first second and contemplate
what it's doing oh it's it's doing the
safety but who the quadratic formula is
through
okay it's safe look you want to start
with a general cubic right xq+ be enough
right I think said will tell me what X
is
I told me what X is there were two of
these it should be three of these right
now you look at this and this looks bad
enough you've got cube roots of square
roots of blah blah
that looks bad but actually it's not
it's even worse because all of these
things underneath the square root if
your eyesight is not that good right all
of these things are also disastrous
things themselves right it's just it's
really terrible
okay now the cubic formula is bad we
went from there we went from there we
went from the quadratic to the cubic and
that's what happened right when you go
through the quarter I said key for the
cubic formula okay
in the quadratic the building blocks are
just a B and C okay when you move up to
the cubic the building blocks become
things that themselves are it's the size
of the quadratic formula okay
when you go to the quartic the building
blocks are things that are the size of
the cubic formula okay now he's my
favorite one right because after three
and then four comes five right so this
is this is this is my favorite by the
way now cubic is 3/4 kisses for critic
is five now when I say there's the quick
follow-up notice I don't say um we just
haven't found it yet okay what's
astonishing is it's been proven that you
can't find a Quinton formula or a hexed
for any degree higher than four right
five and above a formula can't be found
it doesn't exist now this is um you
probably guess you know we're doing
outside the syllabus but I do want to
say to you right now these method to you
one two three then what we call an
algebraic computation right like were
using tools of algebra like these are
all out earlier plus minus square root
squaring that's all algebraic operations
right if you want to find the roots of
anything above this or even practically
speaking if you want to find these rooms
like these formulas exist but no one
here system right because look at them
like you can't even read that me okay
instead of doing that for anything kind
of like this we use methods called
numerical approximation it's in a field
of mathematics called analysis okay so
analysis and we're actually going to
next we're going to learn a couple of
methods for approximately finding what
the solutions to these equations are
because finding that exactly is
ridiculous like it's legitimately
ridiculous right and dog if you want to
find an answer for these things you just
need to get close it off like get me
five decimal places and that'll be
accurate for eight ability or eighty
like architecture or a physical
application you want okay but this is
just astonishing that we can work with
like these things see these simple
simple numbers that you get out of here
the numbers you're adding up and
multiplying and these numbers right and
we reduce something that's insane and so
so difficult that we invent if you feel
and that's to work with them you just
have to like two bytes abilities it's
all you have to do this these results
they just keep going right I could I
could vary a wee word but I could very
easily write no I ain't X to the 5 plus
BX to the 4000 or not right and then
over here you'd have X minus alpha X
minus beta X minus gamma X minus Delta X
minus and so on would be the next one my
Vegas the last words excellent actually
um it's a shade Absalom's really easy
now it's into you with a reverse okay
now here's my point though right like
this
this makes beats me of an impossible
problem okay this is why this is
beautiful it takes something which is
computationally impossible it just makes
it simple like so simple that we can
just like we don't even need calculators
for like the stuff you just look at the
notes you do